Superhero movies have been the biggest thing
at the box office for the past ten years,
and they don't show any sign of slowing down
in 2019.
Here's everything you need to know about the
upcoming comic-inspired blockbusters that
are set to blow you away!
With a runtime of just 75 minutes, 2007’s
animated Superman: Doomsday film barely resembled
the groundbreaking 1994 Death of Superman
comic book saga it was based on.
Fortunately, it taught Warner Bros. a lesson:
fans want the whole story of Superman’s
climactic, bone-shattering battle against
the monstrous Doomsday, and now we’re going
to get it.
That began with the all-new animated Death
of Superman, which debuted at Comic-Con International
in 2018, and expanded the story to feature
the full Justice League taking on Doomsday
before Superman arrived.
It went down so well with critics that its
follow-up, Reign of the Supermen, is getting
a full-on theatrical release as a two-day
double-feature event.
Like its comic book counterpart, Reign of
the Supermen features four pretenders to Superman's
recently vacated throne, the Cyborg Superman,
The Eradicator, Steel, and Superboy, a teenage
clone described as "Superman if he'd been
raised by the Kardashians."
Get ready, it’s set to hit theaters on January
29th, 2019.
If there was any doubt that the upcoming Captain
Marvel film would be set in the ‘90s with
plenty of tributes to the favorite cinematic
hits of that decade, it was taken care of
when the first trailer was released.
There’s a scene where star Brie Larson crashes
through the roof of a Blockbuster Video, right
into the Action section, and it doesn’t
get much more ‘90s than that.
In the comics, Carol Danvers has a long history
that dates back to 1968, and she's gone by
several heroic codenames, including Ms. Marvel,
Binary, and Warbird, and even had her powers
permanently stolen by Rogue from the X-Men.
Since 2012, she’s taken on the identity
of Captain Marvel and become a fan favorite,
and now she’s poised to star in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe’s first film focused
on a female superhero.
That doesn’t mean she’ll be alone, though.
Since it’s a flashback story, moviegoers
can expect to see the return of a few familiar
faces, including Korath the Pursuer and Ronan
the Accuser, last seen in Guardians of the
Galaxy, and a younger Nick Fury and Agent
Coulson in the earlier days of SHIELD.
"What is this?"
"It's a SHIELD logo."
"Does announcing your identity on clothing
help with the covert part of your job?"
Throw in the fact that Carol was positioned
as Nick Fury’s secret weapon at the end
of Infinity War, and we know exactly where
we want to be when Captain Marvel hits the
screen on March 8th.
The word "reshoots" became a dirty one among
DC fans after the disasters that were Suicide
Squad and Justice League, but that hasn't
stopped Warner Bros. from recalling the Shazam!
cast for some last minute tweaks.
This time, though, director David F. Sandberg
has insisted that the tone of the movie, which
star Zachary Levi described as “Big meets
Superman,” won’t be altered.
That’s good news for DC fans who are desperate
for something lighter.
Judging by the trailer, Shazam appears to
be following more in the footsteps of the
colorful adventure of Aquaman rather than
the grim darkness of Batman v. Superman.
There are plenty of jokes, lots of action,
and best of all, Levi actually acts like an
enthusiastic, excited kid in the body of a
superhero.
"That's crazy, right?"
"What are your superpowers?"
"Superpowers?
Dude, I don’t even know how to pee in this
thing!"
After debuting in 1940 as the original Captain
Marvel, Shazam quickly grew to be even more
popular than Superman, and hopefully, this
movie will show a whole new generation of
fans why when it hits theaters on April 5th.
It’s the ultimate wish-fulfillment fantasy
of kids who want to be superheroes themselves,
with a ton of magical action thrown in for
good measure.
Traditionally, three DC Universe Animated
Original Movies are released every year.
It's been this way since 2009 when Wonder
Woman, Green Lantern: First Flight and Superman/Batman:
Public Enemies came out.
For 2019, though, the studio confirmed that
it plans to drop a total of four films, including
one based on Jeph Loeb and Jim Lee's acclaimed
Batman storyline: Hush.
Originally released as a 12-part, year-long
epic, Hush gave readers a mystery story with
a seemingly simple solution, but with enough
complications to bring in Batman’s entire
gallery of foes.
With memorable moments like Batman having
to take down Superman after the Man of Steel
was possessed by Poison Ivy, the Dark Knight’s
relationship with Catwoman being taken to
the next level, and the introduction of the
sinister madman called Hush, it’s been a
fan favorite since it was released.
Avengers: Endgame is coming out on April 26th,
almost a year to the day after Infinity War
was hit theaters.
After the brutal downer of an ending that
saw Thanos committing galactic genocide and
killing off half of the MCU’s superheroes,
though, it feels like we’ve been waiting
a lot longer than a single year to find out
what happens next.
In fact, we didn’t even know the name of
the movie until the teaser finally came out,
but giving it the title “Endgame” is far
from the only ominous thing we’ve gotten
from the trailer.
We’ve seen a world where Tony Stark is recording
his final message to Pepper Potts, perhaps
paving the way for her to take on her own
suit of armor as Rescue, where Hawkeye has
gone rogue and changed his identity to Ronin,
and where it looks like the only way the heroes
can stop Thanos is with the help of… Ant-Man?
"Ant-Man?
Ant-Man!
I know, I know you know that!"
When this guy is your only hope, you know
things have gone seriously bad.
With the Fox-Disney merger now cleared, Marvel's
merry mutants are destined for the MCU.
As a result, X-Men: Dark Phoenix will be a
swan song for Fox's hit-and-miss X-Men franchise.
It hasn’t been an easy road to get here,
though.
The initial release date was bumped to buy
time for extensive reshoots, and there were
rumors that Disney might just can the movie
entirely.
When it comes out on June 7th, it’ll be
the second time that the X-Movies have tried
to adapt the legendary Dark Phoenix Saga,
and fans alre already worried that it’s
going to be botched all over again.
Only time will tell if Sophie Turner will
fare better than Famke Janssen as the doomed
Jean Grey, but if this really is the end of
Fox’s X-Men, then anything could happen.
Oh, come on, you didn’t really think Spider-Man
was dead after Infinity War, did you?
Whatever happens in Endgame, Tom Holland will
be back in action as Peter Parker on July
5th, and while he’s not quite fading to
dust on the moons of Jupiter, he’s still
going to be pretty far from home.
With Peter and his classmates embarking on
a trip to Europe, it seems Spider-Man will
be taking on Mysterio, and maybe even Hydro
Man, in places like Venice and London.
Mysterio, a movie special effects genius turned
super-criminal con man, is an interesting
choice for a villain.
"Who is that guy?"
"He's like Iron Man and Thor rolled into one."
"He’s no Spider-Man."
Like the Vulture, who took center stage in
Homecoming, he’s one of Spider-Man’s classic
Sinister Six, and the hints that he’ll be
discrediting Spidey by acting as a rival superhero
rather than a villain could lead to some really
great fun.
Don’t expect Jake Gyllenhaal to hide his
handsome looks under Mysterio’s classic
comic book bubble helmet for too long, though.
The New Mutants was sold on the idea that
it would be a twist on the familiar tropes
that we’ve seen in superhero films: it’s
a horror movie that just happens to star characters
from Marvel Comics.
Director Josh Boone seemed like the perfect
fit, and his passion for the project made
Fox want to take a chance on him.
Unfortunately, according to reports, the studio
wasn't impressed with what he turned in.
Instead of its scheduled release in April
of 2018, The New Mutants was pushed back ten
whole months to February 2019.
The official reason, according to The Hollywood
Reporter, was that the studio wanted to avoid
overlap with Deadpool 2 in certain overseas
territories, but then it was pushed back even
further to August, fueling rumors that there
was something other than a simple scheduling
conflict going on.
Considering that the source material contains
some of the most legendarily scary stories
to ever be featured on the comics page, we’re
hoping they manage to nail it.
At first glance, the Fatal Five seem like
a pretty unusual set of villains for an animated
Justice League story.
Created by teenage writer Jim Shooter in the
‘60s, the quintet of bad guys were originally
villains for the Legion of Super-Heroes, a
team based in the distant future of the 30th
Century.
Knowing all of that, it won’t surprise you
that they’re a weird bunch of characters,
including the Emerald Empress, who gains her
power from a giant floating magical eyeball,
and Validus, who shoots lightning bolts out
of his exposed brain.
On August 6th, it seems that they’ll be
taking the fight to our very own 21st century
Justice League, which might be a stealthy
way of introducing the Legion of Super-Heroes
to the ongoing line of DC Universe Original
Movies.
While they haven’t been regularly seen in
comics for a few years, they’ve built up
a dedicated fan-base over the past 60 years.
Of course, this could just be a story of the
Justice League taking on a bunch of ultra-powerful
baddies that even most comic book fans haven’t
seen them tangle with before.
That alone makes this one worth checking out,
especially since it’s going to be available
on DC’s streaming service the same day it’s
released to the rest of the world.
He's arguably the most iconic villain in comic
book history, but the Joker has never been
given a truly definitive backstory in print
or on the big screen.
For many fans, that’s even part of his timeless
appeal, but for those of us with a little
more curiosity, Warner Bros. will be offering
up a story of the Clown Prince of Crime’s
earliest days on October 4th, 2019.
With the help of director Todd Phillips and
three-time Academy Award-nominated actor Joaquin
Phoenix, Joker will tell the story of the
man who ultimately becomes Batman’s deadliest
arch-nemesis.
The film is rumored to be a mixture of Alan
Moore and Brian Bolland’s classic Batman:
The Killing Joke graphic novel and Martin
Scorsese's classic King of Comedy, and was
confirmed by the Warner Bros. 2019 Editorial
guide as, quote, "an exploration of Arthur
Fleck, a man disregarded by society, [and]
is not only a gritty character study, but
also a broader cautionary tale."
We know that this will be the fourth DC Universe
Animated Original Movie released in 2019,
but Wonder Woman: Bloodlines still remains
something of a mystery.
Since there’s no existing Wonder Woman comic
with that title, Bloodlines is set to be an
original story, but all we have to go on so
far is an "ominous" teaser poster for the
October 22nd release, featuring a crumbling
temple, possibly hinting at the destruction
of Themyscira.
The success of the live-action Wonder Woman
movie meant that bringing Diana Prince back
to the animated DC universe was a no-brainer.
The Amazon last appeared in a DC Universe
animated film back in 2009, and while it was
critically acclaimed, it didn’t exactly
fly off the shelves.
In fact, as longtime DC animator Bruce Timm
revealed back in 2018, the slow sales actually
made Warner Bros. can a planned Batgirl movie
based on the Batgirl: Year One comic.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel, and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.